in the vast back catalog of superhero
movies slowly making their way to the
screen after the great hollywood
bottleneck of 2020
few entries are as highly anticipated as
the suicide squad
the behind the scenes story behind the
franchise do-over is dramatic enough to
warrant its own blockbuster
after a tactical trolling at the hands
of social media users
guardians of the galaxy director james
gunn was briefly let go by disney
only to have warner brothers snatch him
up a few months later as a result
the dc universe is getting its own gun
brand crew of misfits
using david ayer's critically disastrous
hyper-lucrative 2016 original as a
jumping-off point the film is set to
introduce
a wide array of new anti-heroes to the
dc eu
while expanding on the ones we've
already met but despite a near universal
faith and gun's ability to turn the
suicide squad into a success story
fans have been vocally wondering about
the absence of a certain big league star
first introduced in the 2016 movie but
nowhere to be found here
so just why aren't we getting more of
jared leto's joker in
the suicide squad dc fans will remember
that jared leto's joker was a shot heard
around the nerd world when he first
appeared in promotional images for david
ayers suicide squad
a whole mountain of expectations were
piled on his milky white shoulders
in the lead up to that movie this was
supposed to be a fresh
new joker more unhinged than ever before
and at long last paired with his squeeze
harley quinn on the big screen leto
himself only added fuel to the fire
describing the part in interviews as a
chance to
strike new ground with a beloved villain
sadly the results were mixed at best
die-hard fans of this decidedly edgier
take on the joker are few
and far between as a truncated edit and
less than grounded story left letto's
joker largely underdeveloped and
underutilized
leto would only graze the screen for
about 10 minutes of the two-hour movie
and didn't do much even when he was
around in the eyes of many it just
didn't feel like he had much to do in a
story about extorted pyrokinetics
and extra dimensional sorceresses james
gunn as it turns out
agreed with that assessment and said as
much in a recent interview with the new
york times
asked about whether he considered
bringing leto's joker back into the fray
the filmmaker didn't mince words saying
joker no i just don't know why joker
would be in the suicide squad he
wouldn't be helpful in that type of war
situation
gunn has a point too despite the strange
implications of the justice league
snyder cut sepia tone to epilogue it's
hard to imagine trying to keep a madcap
homicidal clown on the straight and
narrow during a fight harley quinn seems
like enough of a handful on her own and
her sense of morality at least
places her firmly in the anti-hero camp
but the joker enjoys a steadfastly
chaotic evil approach to life
in short he's not a team player
additionally with a pool of more than a
dozen new characters already in play
adding leto's joker to the suicide squad
probably felt like something of a trap
overreaching to include one of the
world's most recognizable villains in
the series first installment was likely
a once bitten
scenario for the studio not only that
but margot robbie has distanced herself
from the portrayal of joker and harley's
relationship in the years since suicide
squad
take that into account and shoehorning
leto into the new story becomes an
even more complicated affair on the
upside mr j's absence doesn't mean that
there won't be plenty of big budget
blockbuster slaughter to go around
gun has been nothing if not clear about
his willingness to gleefully kill off as
many of his characters as he wants at
the drop of a hat
the body counts will be firmed up when
the suicide squad hits theaters and hbo
max on august 5th
2021 check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about your favorite movies are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you